Speaker 1: And another thing another thing that
needs protecting is apparently Dr. Anthony Fauci.
Jesse Waters, Fox News host, came out recently and
said the following. This is at the Turning Point
USA conference again, this is, you know, where
all the wackos love to go. So he said this. This
is where you say, Dr. Fauci, you funded risky
research at a sloppy Chinese lab, the same lab
that sprung this pandemic on the world. That's
not true. You know what? People don't trust you.
You know what, people don't trust you,
don't you hook? Maybe there's a typo,
boom, he is dead, he is dead, he's done.
You do that 30 seconds. It's all you need.
Get us that that's what we want. That changes the
whole conversation of the country. Now, Waters
was suggesting the people, as he put it, ambush
Dr. Foushee if they ever see him in public.
But the boom he is dead, he is dead, he's done
just that. That's what we want. To me, to my ears,
that sounds like a death threat. That sounds
like a Fox News host calling for his supporters
to possibly kill Dr. Anthony Fauci. And, of
course, to somebody like Fauci, that's also
apparently how it sounded because Fauci has now
said this guy should have been fired on the spot.
Fox News, as of this show, has not released
a comment about Jesse Waters statement here.
And of course, there's other ways to interpret
that. If you were actually going to try to convict
him on this, you wouldn't win that case.
And here's why. Because dead can actually
have multiple meanings. He's dead could mean his
career is dead. Could mean his argument is dead.
He was vague enough with what he said to not get
prosecuted for it. But that doesn't excuse it.
And here's the thing found she also
pointed this out in his response,
where he said water should be fired on the spot,
he said they're not so much mad at me and fighting
as me as they're fighting against science.
Because that is what is happening right now.
These Republicans are fighting against science
because science is against them, apparently.
But that's a position that they took.
They decided to make science their enemy,
they decided to make science the antithesis of
what they stand for. They didn't have to do that.
This was a conscious effort made by the
Republican Party that has spanned several
decades now. You know, they're on the wrong
side of science on the issue of climate change.
They're on the wrong side of
science, you know, social sciences.
When it comes to things like trickle down
theory. When it comes to helping the poor.
And, of course, with the pandemic itself as well.
They're always on the opposite side of this,
and that is what they're mad at, but most
importantly, they know how badly Republicans
have screwed this up. So Fauci has become their
punching bag and their fall guy so they can blame
him instead of acknowledging all of their failures
over the past two years. I'm Farron Cousins in for
David Pakman. You can find me on social media,
Twitter, Facebook and Instagram at fair and
balanced and of course, youtube.com slash the
ring of fire. We'll be right back with more.